almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it Donald Trump
had a completely whacked-out speech at a
rally in the conservative stronghold of
Colorado Springs now it's a story for
another day
Colorado Springs Colorado is a
fascinating conservative place
fascinatingly scary I guess I should add
but I do want to highlight a moment from
this completely absurd speech and focus
in on Donald Trump actually bragging
that his followers are completely
cult-like and divorced from any critical
thinking whatsoever that would even
conceivably allow them to say maybe
Trump did something wrong and we should
hold them accountable just like a cult
leader and the more I watch interviews
with Trump supporters I'm reminded more
and more of the book road to Jonestown
by Jeff Quinn that I read it's about
cult leader Jim Jones drink the kool-aid
originates from Jim Jones and I
recommend the book to you it's an aside
but trumpets are reminding me more and
more of Jim Jones followers and more and
more the term cult is actually being
used to describe the supporters of
Donald Trump and Trump is bragging about
this let's take a look at the clip a
visibly sweaty and orange Donald Trump
bragging about his cultist followers
Thank You CNN went up to a woman what
does it take for you to leave the
president I'm not leaving him there were
ten women and the one woman beautiful
did like incredible women and they had
there been times they had hats and
stupid CNN they go up what does it take
for you look he said one time that his
people are so good they'd stay with him
if he shot somebody in the middle of
Fifth Avenue Jay
all right would you say he shot somebody
they actually this is actually something
to the effect would you say if he shot
somebody in the middle for you and the
woman looks well it depends why he shot
him so Donald Trump there was ridiculing
a question that is essentially a de
feasibility test it's what would it take
for you to change your mind about Donald
Trump this is a really great question
that I've talked about before and it can
be very easily used to determine whether
someone is actually thinking critically
and using facts to come to a conclusion
or are they first coming to their
conclusion and then just post facto
interpreting the facts to fit that
pre-existing notion that they have if
there is nothing a president could do to
make you re-examine your support for
them you are not operating in the world
of facts and critical thinking if
someone came to me and said David what
would it take for you to support Donald
Trump I could very clearly tell you
listen if Trump came around on climate
and said he was wrong all along he's
committing to fight climate change if he
came around on trade if he stopped using
the president's need to funnel money
into his own pockets if he apologized
for all the disgusting behavior if he
fixed this fix this tax plan it's a long
list but I would consider saying Trump
might be better than some of these
Democrats that are running I'm at least
trying to operate in the world of
thinking critically and behaving
rationally so Donald Trump is not only
criticizing CNN in the clip for asking
the DES feasibility question he's
actually bragging about how his
supporters are essentially cult
followers they've decided to support
Trump and will after the fact
rationalize anything Donald Trump says
and does it might sound like they're
applying some critical thinking when
Trump says well they'd keep supporting
me if I shot someone depending on why I
shot someone but that entire discussion
has already rationalized a president
even talking about shooting people on
Fifth Avenue and not losing support and
not having his followers abandon him so
this clip should serve as a reminder to
us
given the cult-like nature of Donald
Trump's followers convincing them to
change their minds about who they're
going to vote for in November is so
utterly and obviously futile it is not a
strategy for winning the election what
we have to do is mobilize people who
don't have to be convinced who aren't
part of the cult and Trump bragging
about it is just an additional reminder
of that Trump bragging that his
followers are essentially cultists let's
now get to some other clips from some of
Donald Trump's recent rallies